[Música]
ah
y
[Música]
cuando tenía 17 años decidí estudiar
ciencias económicas tal vez por legado
familiar tal vez sin pensarlo demasiado
me imaginaba que en mi futuro hubiera
estado haciendo balances auditorías o
tal vez liquidando impuestos en ningún
momento de los cuatro años y medio que
duró la carrera estudie un solo tema en
alguna materia vinculado con lo humano
en la organización no sólo esto en mi
cabeza no entraba la categoría de que
alguien pudiera trabajar en recursos
humanos que alguien pudiera trabajar en
los temas de talento de cultura y de
organización
hace más de 25 años que trabajo
exclusivamente en temas de recursos
humanos soy un apasionado y lo que hago
me encanta me siento un privilegiado por
lo que puedo trabajar y no sólo esto
sino que además considero que mi manera
de contribuir al mundo de cumplir con mi
propósito
pero mientras estudiaba tenía un montón
de incertidumbres tenía temores tenía
miedos como la mayoría de los jóvenes
sienten mientras están estudiando cuando
les pregunto a mis alumnos en la
facultad ellos también me manifiestan
que tienen miedos e incertidumbre
respecto a su futuro por favor te pido
que si en algún momento sentiste
incertidumbre o temor respecto a tu
futuro
levanten la mano en este momento
como verán tenemos todo tipo de
respuestas algunos que lo pensaron mucho
otros que ni siquiera se lo pusieron a
pensar y ahora están dando cuenta de lo
que puede ser
le voy a proponer ahora que se paren
paren si todos
lo segundo que van a hacer es sacar sus
teléfonos celulares saquen sus teléfonos
celulares ahora lo van a desbloquear y
en un gesto de confianza de fe y de
arrojo cada uno le entrega su teléfono
celular a la persona que tiene la
derecha háganlo ya mismo tranquilos
confiados bien muy bien
ahora que tiene el teléfono celular de
su vecino lo que les voy a pedir es lo
siguiente traten de focalizarse
exclusivamente en las aplicaciones que
esta persona tenga abierta solo las
aplicaciones no miren más allá de eso
bien ahora devolvemos los teléfonos se
puede sentar y estar un poco más
tranquilos algunos veo muy bien nos
podemos sentar
notemos detener lo siguiente
muchas de estas aplicaciones como puede
ser la agenda el banco o el diario
cambiaron de raíz la naturaleza de
muchos trabajos no sólo esto cambiaron
de raíz la naturaleza de muchas
industrias
la disrupción digital la revolución
digital que estamos viendo ahora ha
cambiado un montón de cuestiones que
hacen a nuestra vida cotidiana pensemos
que el teléfono celular que recién
operamos cada uno de nosotros
tiene solamente 10 años de existencia
hasta hace 11 años cada uno de nosotros
si quería mandar un mensaje escribía un
sms tecleando tres veces en cada tecla
para poder mandar un mensaje de fíjense
lo que ha evolucionado bien dijimos que
vamos a hablar del futuro y del trabajo
empezamos a pensar en el futuro el
futuro es lo que está por venir no
sabemos lo que va a venir lo que tenemos
la certeza es que va a ser muy diferente
a lo que tenemos hoy y se dice que
tenemos la revolución 4.0 que estamos
viviendo la revolución 4.0 porque la
primera revolución fue la industrial la
revolución de la mecanización la segunda
revolución fue la del automóvil la
revolución de la electrificación la
tercera la de la automatización y la
computación más cercana a todos nosotros
pero hoy vivimos una convergencia de
tecnologías donde tenemos la nube
las tres de la inteligencia artificial
la robótica internet de las cosas big
data neurociencias blogs en
biotecnología machine learning deep
learning tenemos la realidad virtual y
la realidad aumentada posiblemente no
sepamos un montón de estas palabras no
que no sepamos la tecnología no sepamos
qué significan estas palabras prever a
un dato hay algunos estudios que dicen
que estas tecnologías dentro de muy poco
ya se van a quedar viejas y vamos a
estar en la revolución 5.0 recuerdo
cuando también contacto con mi primer
computadora una ibm x de 286 en mi
primer trabajo en arthur andersen
recuerdo que tenía un monitor así de
grande ancho una pantalla negra letritas
verdes bien chiquititas y la verdad que
lo utilizábamos solamente como una
evolución de la máquina de escribir que
ingresábamos la información con el disco
flexible y pensábamos que ser
para procesar textos o tal vez para
alguna planilla de cálculo que habíamos
aprendido en un sistema en lenguaje que
llamaba
1 2 3
creo que mis hijos y casi todos los
jóvenes no se imaginarían vivir sin los
dispositivos digitales ni que hablar
trabajar sin un dispositivo digital
pero cada revolución generó más trabajos
que los que destruyó pensemos que
hubiera pasado por la cabeza en un
vendedor de velas cuando se electricidad
pensemos que hubiera pensado quien
vendía caballos para movilidad cuando
salía el automóvil les voy a contar un
dato un reporte reciente del foro
económico global habla que se van a
generar 133 millones de puestos
laborales para el año 2022 pero atención
están en riesgo 75 millones de puestos
laborales qué significa esto que tenemos
58 millones de oportunidades en el medio
la pregunta es decir lado vas a estar
cómo vas a capitalizar estas
oportunidades que se generan acá nomás
en el 2022
dijimos que vamos a hablar del futuro y
que vamos a hablar el trabajo
la verdad que siempre me intrigó para
que te despertás cada día a las 5 de la
mañana a las 6 de la mañana a las 7 de
la mañana que es lo que te motiva para
ir a trabajar ahora fíjense ustedes qué
interesante que en la definición de la
palabra trabajo en el origen de la
palabra trabajo aparece la palabra
tortura instrumento de tortura compuesto
por tres maderos tal vez por la herencia
que tenemos todos nosotros que un
trabajo tenía que ser para toda la vida
que una profesión tenía que ser para
toda la vida
y hoy en día ese paradigma ha cambiado
muchísimo
en mis diálogos con mucha gente de
distintos niveles jerárquicos de
distintas organizaciones percibo una
asfixia en el trabajo mucha gente me
manifiesta que se siente enjaulado de su
trabajo y hablan de la cárcel de oro
algunos la cárcel de plata otros la de
bronce otros simplemente una cárcel
nuevamente te pregunto alguna vez
sentiste esa sensación de asfixia y si
están enjaulados si percibiste esto te
pido que levantes la mano nuevamente
verán que tenemos todo tipo de
respuestas algunos que lo han sentido
otros que ni siquiera tuvieron tiempo
para ver si lo sentían por lo sentían
consideró que el trabajo es el espacio
de nosotros les transmitimos al mundo
todo lo que podemos hacer todo el valor
que le podemos agregar donde pasamos las
horas más importantes del día los
momentos más importantes de nuestra vida
y que mejor de trabajar y aquello que
realmente nos apasiona
imagínate si te vienen a ofrecer un
puesto de ascensorista ascensorista
ascensorista o de operador telefónico
así es como los cables hitos poner
aunque te ofrezcan un puesto de
mecanógrafo escribir a máquina todo el
día estos trabajos que hoy parecen de la
antigüedad hace pocos años eran de lo
más normal y habitual en muchos lugares
ahora sí hace cinco años también ofreció
un puesto de community manager de que si
ibas a trabajar con facebook con twitter
con instagram ibas a trabajar con las
redes sociales y por eso me van a pagar
si hoy no hay empresa que no tenga su
community manager imagínate si tuviera
ofrecer un puesto de operador de drones
oye son las posiciones más requeridas en
el mercado imagínate cero precio
profesor de sombra proceso de zumba que
el gimnasio no tiene profesor de zumba
no tiene profesora de zumba
pensemos que dentro de algunos años
muchos de nosotros vamos a trabajar de
ingenieros de partes del cuerpo o vamos
a trabajar de consultores de bienestar
de la cuarta edad vamos a vivir 90 95
100 105 110 años esté más cómo vamos a
vivir y quién se va a ocupar
de cada uno de nosotros pensemos que
también con el incremento exponencial de
las tecnologías van a haber detectives
digitales esta van a ser profesiones que
van a aparecer seguramente entonces el
tema es qué va a pasar con el trabajo
se dice que muchos de los trabajos que
son repetitivos y de bajo valor agregado
podrían ser sustituidos por un robot o
por la inteligencia artificial en el
momento que el costo de ese robot o la
inteligencia artificial sea inferior al
costo de la persona pero por qué sucede
esto porque los robots son muy buenos
haciendo tareas repetitivas los robots
son excelentes levantando objetos
pesados los robots son increíblemente
buenos haciendo actividades poco
higiénicas que a ninguno de nosotros nos
gusta y los robots son muy buenos
moviendo moviendo objetos con precisión
pero atención nosotros los seres humanos
somos mucho mejor utilizando el sentido
común empatizando con el otro pensando
creativamente innovando sabes por qué
porque ningún robot tiene que hacerse
cargo de un adulto mayor ningún robot
tiene que cuidar a un niño ningún robot
tiene sueños ningún robot tiene
ilusiones
un robot tiene que pagar las cuentas a
fin de mes y ahí tal vez está la sutil
diferencia la pregunta es cómo nos
preparamos para esto que se viene qué es
lo que vamos a hacer para prepararnos
para este cambio tan radical y
exponencial que se viene la primera
distinción que quisiera ofrecerles es
hablar de empleabilidad cambiar de
empleo a empleabilidad en la habilidad
de tener empleo hoy marianna tres años
cinco años necesarios en segunda
instancia la fundación nacional de las
ciencias de eeuu nos habla de ciencia
tecnología ingeniería y matemática como
las cuatro grandes áreas de conocimiento
que tenemos que desarrollar para estar
tecnológicamente a la altura de los
desafíos
pero el multipremiado politzer thomas
friedman nos habla de la empatía porque
porque dice que la ciencia tecnología
ingeniería temática son importantes pero
la empatía es crítica para poder
desarrollar soluciones veamos un ejemplo
vas al mejor médico del mundo hace un
diagnóstico impecable y lamentablemente
el tumor es maligno ahora la manera como
te va a comunicar ese médico ese
diagnóstico es tan importante como el
diagnóstico en sí mismo para empezar tu
tratamiento y empezar la mejora
inmediatamente
la escuela de diseño de
road rhode island nos habla de la prima
porque es en ciencia tecnología
matemática pero además las artes porque
lo científico cada vez es más artístico
y lo artístico cada vez es más
científico entonces creo que tenemos que
entender que se vienen nuevas
alfabetizaciones el profesor joseph e
iun de la northeastern university es
quien más investigo su libro es como ser
a prueba de robots y en lo que nos dice
es que para no ser los nuevos
analfabetos del siglo 21 tenemos que
desarrollar tres áreas de conocimiento
datos tecnología y fundamentalmente la
humana que es donde nosotros los humanos
nos destacamos
evidentemente lo que se viene no sabemos
con lo cual tenemos que aprender a
aprender aprender para tratar de
incorporar todo eso nuevo que se viene
y si quieres emprender el futuro de una
manera distinta recordad incrementa tu
empleabilidad a través de la ciencia la
tecnología la ingeniería la matemática
más la empatía más las artes alfabetiza
te en datos en tecnología y
fundamentalmente en lo humano aprende a
aprender porque todo lo nuevo está por
venir pero fundamentalmente poner el
ingrediente secreto es la pasión
apasionante con tu trabajo y trabajar de
lo que te apasiona
hablo con mucha gente y posiblemente a
más de uno de ustedes en este momento
esté transcurriendo esta emoción en el
cuerpo de angustia por los robots sin
embargo considero que sí enfrentamos el
futuro con un rol protagónico con
dignidad con humanidad con seriedad y
con compromiso ya ello le azules le
sumamos la pasión no tengo dudas y lo
mejor podría estar por venir porque
porque ello depende fundamentalmente de
cada uno de nosotros
[Música]
ah
y